100 um post malone's somebody who
embraced you really early
um
uh like i said i'm looking forward to
the tour that's coming out obviously
cooped up is crazy yeah uh
talk about y'all's friendship because
he's a great guy somebody you can hang
out with get drunk with you know what
i'm saying i've lost a beer pong a bunch
of times against him yeah yeah
talk about that friendship man uh like i
said he a real [ __ ] more so than
anything i feel like this is just a full
circle moment that's doing this tour
together it's more so just
speaks volumes of him and our
relationship our friendship he took me
out on the road and he had already sold
out the europe tour so just getting back
on the road with him and doing it the
right way is feel like perfect timing
for like
a good time to do that [ __ ] have you uh
ever participated in a game of beer pong
against postie yeah
yeah did you hang in there
yeah i'd be cool bro that [ __ ] don't
really bother me like
i don't really get drunk like that to be
honest what's the go to like if you're
drinking though are you i've everyone's
been on tequila really since the
pandemic started so yeah does it mean
are you still on the tequila or what are
we doing the tequila cool uh you know i
feel like
i need to really just make my own
tequila that's like that would be the
that would be the play
yeah everyone's got uh uh old enough
though
how'd you gotta be to make your own
tequila i think 25
really like to sponsor it in yeah
i think so
damn same with cars you can't sponsor a
car company well you know you can't rent
a car by yourself unless you're 25
what i'm saying like you can't even you
if you're 25 like i couldn't like like
i'm glad i'm in the position i mean [ __ ]
uh no you're obviously if i just mean in
general like guys can't even rent cars
unless you're 25. no i know what you're
saying that's why i'm just i'm [ __ ] i'm
grateful being a position i ain't got a
rent how many cars you got
[Music]
why eight nine eight so give me your
your favorite car and your most
expensive car that you own
uh
my favorite car my first car my hellcat
the one i bought in 20 2018
19
uh 2020 um
it's a daytona edition
okay uh i think they made like 500 of
those it's inc inside the first car i
got with blue stitching oh nice
blue detail and [ __ ] and then i put it
on 4g that's like my favorite car but
uh my most expensive cars is derozan
and a rory
the ferrari yeah yeah the ferrari's uh
it's a serious boy man both of them have
oh cool
yeah i feel like any car that i could go
that fast in i'm probably i'm just i'm
freaked out about it yeah i got
something else for the ass though i'm
about to do some [ __ ] ain't nobody ever
did
well probably [ __ ] done did it but
not in the last 10 years what
get a new car
fire [ __ ]
fire [ __ ] like an old school nah some
new [ __ ]
but whatever well what is it that you
haven't that people haven't done in 10
years they got to see it you know if i
say it air you feel me it's gonna air
[ __ ] don't see it and they're just
gonna try to do it i'm gonna just pop up
with that [ __ ] though you
getting the old-school hummer no i don't
know i'm just trying to figure out i'm
thinking 10 years ago i'm thinking 10
years ago no i'm saying that a [ __ ]
ain't dead like i ain't seen nobody
really bust it
so it's time for me to just go and make
that my lane
would you consider yourself a car
enthusiast
no i just like i just like cars like
it's just a thing i like cars i like
uh diamonds and i like certain shirts
obviously there's a lot of there's a lot
of uh diamonds on your neck man that's a
it's a serious amount of uh of ropes
yeah shout out to your jeweler whoever
did those is definitely uh
appreciating your
your your your customer ship for sure
best jewel in the game who's your who's
your driller
elliott
shout out to elliot yeah he got wayne
though he got a future he got some
[ __ ] that's spending more money to me